that's what we like have this one handy
as well
so zinc again is it's an abundant metal
but it's a metal that we all need for
life it's part of enzymes and it's part
of many many biologically mediated
processes I don't know what else to say
I think it's a pretty boring metal
really is a boring metal now I
understand one of my colleagues said
thinks a bit boring this isn't always
the case and when you combine it with
some other elements it can get quite
frisky as you'll see in a bit
zinc is a really soft metal sort of
grayish in color it reacts very easily
with acids to produce hydrogen in fact
it's the way that people make hydrogen
in the lab or used to now they usually
buy it in cylinders zinc is often found
on things like rooves as well very very
high quality roofing material very slow
to oxidize zinc is used very widely as a
coating on iron so called galvanizing
you put a thin layer of zinc and the
zinc then corrodes instead of the iron
so that it stops the an rusting at least
for quite a long time you can see it on
corrugated iron roofs a metal gates in
the countryside and so on so this is
diethyl zinc so it's c4h10 said n zinc
is quite important biologically and
there are all sorts of enzymes in our
bodies that use zinc and particularly
one called carbonic anhydrase that
catalyzes the reaction of co2 and water
and so without zinc none of us could
survive the delivery of the statement
that zinc is boring were greatly under
anticipating the result of this
experiment
all right you built it up there that's
what we like to say I have this one
handy as well
let's give this a go whoa so who says
thanks boring
should we do again well now I don't
think the sinks is in the least bit
boring
I will think that most elements are
interesting but zinc is interesting
because it's in the same group as
cadmium and mercury and cadmium and
Mercury are both pretty poisonous but
zinc is essential to life if you don't
have enough zinc you can't smell things
there are all sorts of enzymes in your
body and those of other creatures that
won't work without zinc so it's really
good you may be bored about it but if
you didn't have zinc you wouldn't even
be able to be bought